esta vez nos dicen el dueño de un
restaurante ha instalado una máquina
dispensadora de bebidas la máquina está
diseñada para servir 530 mililitros de
líquido en el vaso mediano el dueño
sospecha que la máquina podría estar
sirviendo el líquido en exceso en los
vasos medianos se decide tomar una
muestra de 30 bebidas de este tamaño de
vaso para verificar la cantidad promedio
es significativamente mayor que 530
mililitros cuáles son las hipótesis
adecuadas para la prueba de
significancia y nos dan cuatro opciones
como siempre pagos el vídeo y ver si
puedes resolver el problema
bien vamos a trabajarlo juntos
recordemos primero que es una hipótesis
nula y que es una hipótesis alternativa
una manera de ver a la hipótesis nula es
considerarla como la hipótesis que
establece lo que se espera en ocasiones
se describe como la hipótesis de la no
diferencia y por lo general en ella
establecemos una expresión de igualdad
en la cual el parámetro poblacional es
igual al valor que éste está suponiendo
que debe de tener en la hipótesis
alternativa establecemos aquello para lo
cual podríamos tener evidencia y que se
estaría modificando lo que hasta ese
momento considerábamos válido en el
parámetro poblacional es decir en la
hipótesis alternativa postulamos que si
hay una diferencia para este ejemplo la
no diferencia o la hipótesis nula es el
parámetro que nos interesa que en este
caso es la cantidad promedio de bebida
que el dispensador sirve para el vaso
mediano y es justo lo que me dicen aquí
por lo que en este caso el parámetro
poblacional es la media y estamos
diciendo que la media debe de ser igual
a 530 mil litros pues ese es el valor
para el cual fue programado el
dispensador y la hipótesis alternativa
lo que nos dice en esta ocasión es lo
que teme el dueño en este caso el dueño
teme que esta media sea más grande que
530 mililitros así que veamos cuál de
estas es la opción correcta bueno
observa las primeras dos son para
proporción pero en este caso lo que nos
interesa es la cantidad promedio aquí lo
puedes ver se decide tomar una muestra
de 30 bebidas de este tamaño de vaso
para verificar si la cantidad promedio
es significativamente mayor que 530
mililitros
la cantidad promedio no están hablando
de proporciones están hablando de
promedios lo cual corresponde estimar el
parámetro poblacional y ese va a ser la
media la media poblacional de cuántas
bebidas el sirve específicamente para el
tamaño mediano así que esta opción no
parece ser la correcta el inciso c es la
opción correcta solo tenemos estas dos
que tienen que ver con la media la
diferencia entre esta y esta otra es que
para esta la media es mayor que 530
mililitros lo cual es de hecho lo que
teme el dueño mientras que para ésta
la hipótesis alternativa es que se está
sirviendo en promedio menos que 530
mililitros
lo cual no es lo que teme el dueño no es
lo que deseamos constatar entonces
definitivamente es la opción ser bien
hagamos otro ejemplo la fundación
nacional para el sueño recomienda que
los adolescentes entre 14 y 17 años de
edad duerman por lo menos 8 horas cada
noche para una
salud y bienestar un grupo de
estadística de una preparatoria sospecha
que los estudiantes de su escuela
duermen en promedio menos de 8 horas
diarias para probar esta teoría
eligieron aleatoriamente una muestra de
42 estudiantes y les preguntaron cuántas
horas duermen cada noche la media para
la muestra es de 7.5 horas la cantidad
promedio que duermen en cada noche los
estudiantes de la escuela es como se
completan adecuadamente su hipótesis
alternativa pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes contestar esto
bien el primero pensemos en lo que sería
la hipótesis nula adecuada déjame
ponerle aquí la hipótesis no la adecuada
bueno en este caso va a estar dada al
considerar que no hay nada diferente con
respecto a lo que todo el mundo supone
así que la hipótesis no la es que los
estudiantes están durmiendo cada noche
por lo menos ocho horas para su
bienestar recuerda que nos interesa la
población de estudiantes de esta escuela
y entonces la hipótesis nula relacionada
con el parámetro de la población es que
la media del tiempo que los estudiantes
duermen es mayor o igual que ocho horas
y una buena pista para la hipótesis
alternativa es cuando te encuentras a
algo de este estilo cuando dice
un grupo de estadística de una
preparatoria sospecha aquí está la
palabra clave sospechan que las cosas
pueden ser distintas a lo que se ha
venido suponiendo que es benéfico para
los estudiantes ellos sospechan que los
estudiantes de su escuela duermen en
promedio menos de 8 horas diarias
entonces sospechan que el parámetro
poblacional es decir la media
poblacional para su escuela es en
realidad menor que 8 horas y si queremos
escribir esto con palabras entonces
podríamos poner aquí la cantidad
promedio que duermen cada noche los
estudiantes de la escuela es menor
que ocho horas y ya está ahora hay dos
cosas con las cuales tenemos que tener
cuidado
primero asegurarnos de que estamos
usando el parámetro adecuado en
ocasiones es la media poblacional y en
otras es la proporción poblacional y
segundo en ocasiones las personas se
confunden pues aunque estamos calculando
un estadístico a partir de una muestra
aquí estamos calculando la media
muestral el estadístico muestral no es
al que hacen referencia las hipótesis lo
puedes ver aquí las hipótesis son hace
operaciones sobre la población que nos
interesa aquí la población son los
estudiantes de preparatoria bueno pues
ya tenemos la respuesta así que nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo